- Hey everyone, this is Jeremy Schieffelin
with Khan Academy.
Thanks so much for
joining us this afternoon.
You're in for a very special treat today
because we have kind of Academy ambassador
and all star male teacher,
Shalom with us today
who has been using Khan
Academy for almost a decade.
Basically since Sal Khan himself
started making the videos,
Shalom has been with us
using it in his classroom.
So if you're ever curious
about how do you get started
with Khan Academy for remote learning,
how do you specialize
and target your content
for your middle school students?
Shalom is the person to speak to
and he's happy to share
his expertise today.
So that being said,
before we get you
Shalom's background here,
I wanna remind you the
first part of the session
we focused on the most
common questions we received
and Shalom will talk
through how to get started
and how to focus your
energies with Khan Academy.
And then we'll open it
up for the final half
for questions from the audience.
So if you ever wanna ask a question,
just go to the question section
of the go to webinar control panel
and we'll take those in
the order they're received.
So Shalom, welcome and thank you so much
for joining us today.
- It's very nice to be
here with everybody.
- And just to sort of
give folks a sense of
where you're coming from,
tell us a little bit about
where you teach, who you
teach and what your experience
with Khan has been.
- Okay, I'm a seventh grade math teacher
in Ocean Township, New Jersey.
Teaching is a second career for me,
I actually worked on Wall
Street for six years,
and decided to make the switch
and I've been teaching
middle school ever since.
So here I am in Monmouth
County, New Jersey. (laughs)
- Very cool.
And so tell us, like, even
before this crisis started,
why have you been a Khan
user in your classroom?
- At about the 2010/2011 school year,
a friend of mine had told me about it.
And I had heard about this
Khan Academy videos thing,
but she told me, "Oh, no,
no, it has exercises."
So I was really drawn to the exercises.
Back then they had to
get either seven in a row
or 10 in a row right to level up.
And I was like, this is
how we learn everything.
So primarily I didn't
have computers back then.
I used it initially for extra credit.
But I continue to use it to this day.
It's my primary source of
practice problems for students.
I use others, but it's my primary source.
And I love the fact that students
can go at their own pace.
They're not, it really
allows them to learn
what they want at their level.
And it provides such good
data for me as a teacher
to decide when to intervene,
what to intervene,
what trends there are, things like that.
- Very cool.
And so obviously you could probably give
an entire three hour lecture
on how to set up Khan Academy
during normal times.
- I really could. (laughs)
- (laughs) The times we
live in are very abnormal
all of a sudden.
If you are an educator out
there, a middle school teacher
who is struggling to
get with remote learning
basically yesterday and the
district is saying, "Hey, you've
"got to roll something
out for your students."
Obviously number one,
our hearts go out to you.
But number two, what kind
of like really concrete tips
would you give to that educator
who wants to get started immediately?
- Okay, first of all, I'm very fortunate,
my students are conditioned
on how to use Khan Academy.
And I know it's scary to, "Oh my God,
"how am I gonna start with something new?"
So my recommendation is to
go through some exercises
as a student (mumbles)
answer them yourself,
but make sure they are review exercises.
Start with something
that the kids would know.
Start small, assign a few skills for them
and then just at that point, dive in,
meaning you assign it to them.
You tell them, "Here,
go do this by Friday,"
and let them work and then
take a look at the data
that comes in, take a
look at what students
are working on.
Are they getting them
correct or are they not?
So you wanna start small
because you don't wanna overwhelm the kids
with a bunch of stuff,
which is why I think
for right now it would be
good to start with review.
But then once you get started,
make sure to look at all the reports,
try to understand it's,
I know it's so hard
to see the forest through the trees.
But that would be my big piece of advice.
And here's where I'm gonna
give you a shout out, Jeremy.
A few weeks ago you did a workshop
and you talked about adding.
It was, once you add yourself as a coach
to your own account.
And I think that was actually something
I had never thought to do
considering the amount of
time I've spent using Khan.
And by doing that I started
seeing the same notifications
that the students would see.
You know, here's something
your teacher assigned you.
I started getting email notifications.
So you kind of by adding
yourself as a coach
to your own learner side of the account,
'cause every account can be a
learner and a coach account,
it really kind of helped me understand,
I already kind of knew what they saw
but it really let me, it
kind of put it in my face
to see what the students are seeing
when I assign them things.
- Very cool.
So just to recap those three main steps,
it sounds like number one,
just start searching around Khan Academy,
playing the role of a student.
What does it feel like to look at a video?
What does it feel like to do an exercise?
Get some hints.
Once you see one that
you're really excited about,
maybe just start by assigning
a single assignment at a time
just to sort of dip your toes in the water
and get your students feeling comfortable
and then to really
understand what it looks like
from the student lens, come
down to your student section,
get your class code, and
then under your learner home,
you can find the section called
teachers at the very bottom
and add yourself to your own classroom.
You'll now see those notifications
that Shalom talked about.
So you understand exactly
what it feels like
to be in your students' shoes.
- Yeah, and the other
thing too is in this time
that we're in the videos
tend to take a little longer.
I would just start at
first with the exercises.
Yeah, this is just practical advice
so that you can quickly
see, "Oh, is this something
"I'd want my students doing?"
And if it is right at
the top of the screen,
if you pick an exercise right now,
can you just pick one and show everybody
how they can assign it to their students
right from the top of the screen?
- Yeah, tell me like a common
skill you might be teaching
in your classroom right now, Shalom
if we were back in school.
- Well this time of year,
I'm doing some geometry
with my advanced class.
So if you go to seventh grade geometry.
So let's just go to Area of
a Circle, second one there.
- So click the practice button.
- So you're in the student view.
The student have to answer seven questions
and you say, "Wait a minute,
"I really like this question up here."
So at the top there's
assigned to, all right,
you can assign it to multiple classes,
you can assign it to individual students
as long as it's for one class only.
If you have multiple classes,
you're just gonna assign it
to every student in the class.
I prefer to do different questions
or you can also assign the
same questions to everybody
different questions the way I go.
And then you can set a due date.
Now this will come up on
their learner dashboard.
But this right here will not
come up on Google classroom.
That's something teachers, I
know you can link your class
to Google classrooms to get
your roster into Khan Academy,
but assignments don't automatically go out
to Google classroom.
And I'm hoping that they
are working on changing that
in the future.
- Yeah, I'll just mention on that point,
if you ever have feedback
for us about something
you'd love to see in the product,
just go right up to your name
in the upper right hand corner,
click the help button and then
come to the section called
report a problem and say, "Hey, I've got
"a really great feature idea
"that would make things
much, much better."
I'll actually paste this
in to the chat section
so you can let us know
if you have problems
or ideas you want us to consider.
Okay, so that is sort of getting started
with checking it out.
What are some of the
challenges that you anticipate
the teachers will face in
the next few weeks, Shalom?
I know we have a lot of things
on our shoulders right now,
but if you think about
Khan Academy in particular,
where do you see new
teachers you run into issues
and how can they sort of
preempt those best they can?
- Okay.
My biggest challenge with Khan Academy
has always been getting students
to buy into the growth
mindset aspect of it.
You know, it's not just,
"Here's five problems,
"do them, great, you got four wrong,
"let's move on to the next topic."
It's really designed to have the kids work
until they show levels of proficiency.
So two things that I make all
my students and parents do
at the beginning of the year
is I make them watch the, "You
Can Learn Anything Video".
And also there's about a five,
six minute or so Ted talk
by Angela Lee Duckworth on grit.
So it's kind of to get them set.
And by the way, she talks about how
she was a seventh grade
teacher and how perseverance
and all these things to
get students in the mindset
of you're not gonna get everything right.
You're gonna make mistakes along the way
and that it's okay as
long as you keep going.
Those are the two things I think that
are the biggest challenges that I've had.
And I've had some tough times,
especially in my earlier years
with parents complaining about
how frustrated their child is.
But since I've started doing that,
I've gotten much better
appreciation from the parents
and from the students
that struggling is okay.
I always say, "Why is
it okay to be terrible
"when you first play an instrument?"
I mean, you don't see
somebody pick up the flute
and they're playing it
and they sound great.
They sound awful, right?
And why is it not
acceptable in math to be bad
at something at first?
So that's my first thing.
Also another challenge
is the amount of content
can be overwhelming.
It really, really can.
But thankfully if you click on
courses there for me, Jeremy?
Right.
- You got it.
- You will see the courses are aligned
with the common core
standards, which by grade.
So if you go down, I'm looking
at your screen right now,
first grade, second grade,
third grade, fourth grade.
So you can go in there and
find the exercises by standard.
There's also a Common Core
math which I think is okay.
It's great for high school
teachers, but K to eight,
the standards are really
well aligned by grade.
So you can, or you can,
there's the Common Core math.
It's those grade one,
there's 28 unique skills
and 605 questions and so on and so forth.
This is a different view,
but I prefer the other view
where you go into the grade itself.
But I know it's overwhelming
to see all that information,
but if you narrow it down,
find exercises you like,
try them out and assign
them to your students
and then just see where
it goes from there.
- Great, great advice.
So really sort of start with
a little bit of inspiration,
setting the bar high,
letting your students know
that you believe in them
even when the challenge
is so strong right now.
And then number two, finding the stuff
that really brings them back
to that sense of normalcy
of like, "Hey, we would have
been covering this right now
"and so we're gotta keep
going ahead and not give up."
- Yes.
- Last question before we
opened up for more questions
from the audience is if you
think a couple of weeks ahead,
the teachers have taken your
advice for getting started,
they've made a couple of assignments
and now maybe the pressure is really on
to deliver kind of classroom
instruction on a regular basis
and really take the most
of tools of Khan Academy.
Are there any more
advanced tips or techniques
from your middle school experience
that you would recommend
for a middle school educator out there?
- I'm sorry, I was coughing there.
I think that, can you repeat
the end of that question
'cause I coughed at the end?
- Oh no, no.
My apologies.
Yeah, just thinking ahead,
like I know personally
in my kids' own district here,
there's a lot of discussion
right now about going
from peer sort of like keep the
lights on day in and day out
to how do we actually have clear plans,
clear structures in place to mimic
as much classroom instruction as possible.
If a teacher is facing
that kind of challenge
over the next few weeks or months,
what can they do on Khan
Academy to go above and beyond
just one assignment?
What turns it into a
system, into a process?
- Okay.
First of all, if this is tough for people
to wrap their heads around,
but if you are okay,
if you can get yourself
okay with students working
at their own pace, right?
If you have them start
to work through a unit,
can you pull up, before
the session started,
we talked about the mastery point system.
Okay, so that's kind
of small on my screen.
I don't know how it would look
on other people's screens,
but--
- There you go.
- Okay, perfect.
Zero points means a student.
So this all has to do with exercise set.
So zero points means either a student has,
I'm trying to point my mouse,
but I'm guessing that either
have never started it, no level
or they've attempted it.
If you see the little diamond
in the bottom right corner,
that means they've gotten less
than 70% on that problem set.
Then if the student gets at least 70%,
they get to 50 points, which is familiar.
And then if they get
100% in that problem set,
they get 80 points and
they're proficient, right?
And the last 20 points
they can get mastered,
they have to do one of two ways,
either by taking a unit
test on Khan Academy
or by answering them correctly
on what's called the mastery challenge.
All right, if you say to the students,
let's go to seventh grade geometry
or seventh grade anything.
- Sure.
- And you asked the students,
okay, you know what,
start at the beginning.
By the way, I wouldn't
necessarily start with geometry.
It's not the,
let's do negative numbers
addition, subtraction here.
Let's use that, and say to the students,
"All right, get started."
All right, if you go down,
you're gonna have to scroll
to the, there's the first
skill signs of sums.
They're not actually, they're
gonna see instead of mastered,
they're gonna see a
little blue button there
that says start.
And that's how they
can get to the exercise
and then say, okay, go
from there to the next one,
adding negative numbers, right?
And the point system that I just discussed
is on the right side there.
Now your account or
whoever's account this is,
has already mastered all those.
So it's kind of not the best example
because this person
already mastered all these.
But if you have the students
start at the first skill
in negative numbers and
work their way through
and say, "Listen, I just want
you to work 30 minutes a day
"and try to watch videos, do
exercises, see how you do."
And you use that point
system in the reporting
that you get as well.
And that point system helps you determine
what it is that students
need more help with.
- And do you wanna talk very briefly
about these progress reports?
Just because I think
that'll help folks really
draw the connection between
what the students are seeing
and doing and what the
teacher is responding with.
- Okay, so let's go to solving
equations and inequalities.
So if you click on that, right?
And you scroll down a little bit.
All right, not started right
now, there are eight students
that are not started and
that's their names right there.
That's the zero points.
Attempted, there's one student.
Attempted means they got less than 70%.
Familiar, we have no
students in that category.
So those are students that
have 70%, but less than 100%.
Proficient is a student
that did the exercise
and they got all the questions right.
So they got 100%, they moved to proficient
and it looks like Meaghan,
she eventually answered the
question correct on a unit test
or did a mastery challenge and
she got those last 20 points
and that's where she gets the mastered.
So the point system that I
talked about before is related
that's on the student
side, what they can see.
This is on the teacher
side, what you can see.
So if you ask your
students to start on a unit
and just say, "Just go with it, here."
Take whatever minutes
a day and go with it.
You'll start getting
this report to populate
and you'll see who's
getting it and who's not.
And this is what I do in my
class during the regular year.
I know it's kind of tough to do that
or to even think about
doing that in this time,
but this is actually
the most meaningful part
of the website for me
is that students are
working at their own pace.
And I tell the kids just 'cause
you're struggling with something
or your friend is struggling
with something, but you're not,
why should I give you homework
on the same topic every day?
So this might be the perfect test case
for doing something like that.
- Yeah, I mean, it's hard to
find silver linings right now,
but if ever there was a
moment in American education
when we could actually
try to serve each student
where they are, this might be
that one with tools like this.
- Listen, ideally I'd be
working below grade level
and having my kids work their way up.
But I'm still responsible
for grade level assessments
and grades and things like that.
So this is a time where a lot of people
can kind of experiment
with, "Hey, you know what?
"I think this is the best
way my students can learn
"and let me just try it."
So, yeah.
- Cool.
Well, amazing advice Shalom.
I think you've given folks a lot
to get started with already.
Let's dive into the
more specific questions
coming from the audience,
starting with a gray one from Janice.
So Janice is talking a little
bit about the experience
that students have of
doing these exercises
and she says, "What strategies Shalom,
"have you found effective
in getting kids to self-help
"by using those hint resources
and going back to rework
"and redo their exercises to
improve their understanding?"
One thing I've seen a lot
observing middle school students
is kids don't wanna use hint
because it seems like a sign of weakness.
They don't wanna do it again
'cause it seems like, oh
maybe they didn't do so well
the first time.
How do you overcome that and
get them to help themselves?
- Well, I'll answer it in two ways.
Number one in class I have a rule.
I won't answer your question
unless you've attempted the problem.
And I tell the kids, even if you guessed,
even if it's a multiple choice question
and you guess correctly,
then raise your hand.
Say, "Mr lab, I guess this right,
"but can you explain it to me?"
So we are almost kind
of forcing that hint now
because we're not right
there to help them.
So my whole thing is encourage
and this is where the
growth mindset comes in.
This is where it's okay.
Like I always use this
example with my students.
My son was eight years old,
taught himself to solve a
Rubik's cube and made fun of me
because I couldn't do it.
And then I had to learn how to do it.
I mean, I couldn't let him beat me.
And when I did, it took me
a lot longer to learn it
than it took him.
So I used that as a growth mindset lesson.
I didn't give up.
Am I stupid because it
took me longer than him?
Maybe.
But I think most people would
say, "Wow, you're a person
"who can solve a Rubik's cube now."
And it doesn't matter
if it takes you longer
and that's the kind of thing that I think
if you can get your
students to understand,
that's why I like those two videos
that you can learn anything
and the grit videos
'cause it kind of gets
kids in that mindset.
So, great question.
Harder to do than just
saying go ahead and do this.
But good luck Janice, right?
- Yeah, all right, great question Janice.
Great response Shalom.
Courtney I think is gonna push
us to go back a little bit.
This is important for those
who are just really getting started today.
"What's even required for
a middle school students
"to get started with a Khan Academy?
"Is all they need an email?
"How do they even get sort
of integrated into the system
"in the first place?"
- Okay, first of all,
if your district has a
G-suite or Gmail email handle,
that makes it easy right there
because all you need to do
is when you go to, excuse
me, when you go to Settings.
Are we in teacher tools?
I'm sorry.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Okay.
- Maybe Sync with Google Classroom?
- Yeah, right there, Sync
with Google Classroom.
I didn't know if it was in
the teacher setting or the,
and you just,
this account's already
synced with her Google class.
This is Meaghan's account, right?
- That's right.
- So hit Sync and now that
roster will be in there.
Now if you don't have a
Google suite email address
in your district, there's the class code.
Now the students, I always
prefer they do things
with their district email address.
But you can send them this class code
and they add themselves to your class.
The one thing I always stress
is when students log in,
if it is a Google account,
make sure to log in through Google.
A lot of times people see the login screen
and they see an actual like
place to enter a username
and password.
You don't need it if
it's a Google account,
you just link it to your Google account.
- And let me actually
show what that looks like
from the new user standpoint.
So, you were coming to
Khan Academy as a student
and you said start here,
said, "Hey, I'm a learner."
Just to be clear, your recommendation is
better to put in a class
code than anything else?
Shalom, is that right?
- Well no.
If you're Google I
would start right there.
Continue with Google.
- Okay, Continue with Google, cool.
- Do me a favor, click Sarah.
Is it gonna ask for the
date of birth anymore?
Is that gonna just?
- Yeah, so I believe it
offers that based on the fact
that this person is over 13.
But yeah, you can also do a
Google or you can do class code,
which again is pulled straight
from your classroom settings.
Okay, great feedback.
- And the age, correct me if I'm wrong,
but the age shouldn't be an issue
if you're using it with a school account.
That's one of the reasons I also recommend
using a school account.
Because I think--
- That's exactly right.
- Okay.
- Okay, great question Courtney.
Thanks for the response from Shalom.
- I hope I answered it.
- (laughs) Gerard from Ocean Township says
"Shalom, where did you
get that awesome headset?"
- Oh, (laughs) Gerard is messing with me.
Gerard is my supervisor.
So, (laughs)
- You better be on your best behavior.
- This is my session of pilot headset.
That's pretty funny, Gerard.
I give you prompts for asking
that question. (laughs)
- Cool.
I think we're all in
the market for headsets,
all of us that in.
So definitely if you have
a recommendation Shalom,
let us know.
So Belinda has a really
good question, which is,
"Okay, we've talked a
lot about the technology,
"but what about the
teacher-student interaction piece?
"How would you recommend
giving feedback to students
"once you start getting
these progress reports?"
- Okay, first of all,
in terms of feedback,
the students are getting
immediate feedback
if they answer a question right or wrong.
Yes, the hints are not
the most exciting for them
to look at.
But it is instant feedback
and I've been doing it for years
and I try to get my students,
"Read the hints, please
"and then ask me the question."
And sometimes they wear you down.
Sometimes they ask me a question,
and I don't even ask them, "Did
you look at the hints yet?"
Some exercises, I don't
necessarily love the hints.
I think that not that they're wrong.
I just don't think that
they're the most simplified way
of showing things.
So it's the feedback in the classroom
is I can use that data to kind
of pick a group of students,
"Wow, these seven kids are
struggling with this skill.
"Let me work with them."
Use that to maybe do a Zoom conference
with a small group of kids.
I bought myself this right here.
It's a little tablet
that I can use to write
and I make Sal Khan style videos myself
as kids ask me questions.
You can make those if you look at,
there's a certain report you can look at
and see how many students in the class
answered it correctly or incorrectly.
And Khan actually puts it in
order from the most difficult
to the, I'm sorry, the one
that's most frequently wrong
to the ones that have been easiest.
So if you, let's pull that up real quick.
So if you see a problem, you're like,
"Wow, a lot of kids are
getting this wrong,"
and you wanna do a quick
video for it in this,
in class you would obviously do it.
Here's a question only three students
were presented with a question seven.
Two of the students got it wrong,
one student got it right.
My favorite part is to the right.
It shows you what answers were chosen.
And by the way, this is a
multiple choice question.
If you can find one that
is not multiple choice,
I think everything in this
set is multiple choice.
But you can, even if the
question is not multiple choice,
it will tell you what students
typed in as their answer.
So this kind of information is
fantastic and you can use it,
as you please.
Now in the setting that
we're in, remote learning,
it's not gonna be easy and
you have to find your way
of conveying that to your students,
whether it be videos or
webinar, chat style things,
video chats I should say.
But the information is there
to help you make those decisions.
And that's the beauty.
That's what I love about
Khan Academy the most.
It really helps me.
By the way, I have to give a shout out
to my co-teacher, Suzy
'cause Gerard got mentioned, so.
(Jeremy laughs)
(Shalom laughs)
- (mumbles) far and wide.
Yeah, no, I think you
just nailed it though.
I want to echo that last sentiment
which is I think a lot of
teachers will look at Khan Academy
and say "Ah, this is just
trying to replace the teacher
"somehow just like my
classroom on autopilot."
You couldn't be farther from the truth
because really isn't the tool
and the teachers who are using it the best
are the ones who are using it
to drive their own teaching,
to get more information to
serve their students better?
- And if there's something
I want everybody to know is,
and I've given presentations
about Khan Academy
and how to use it.
And one of the things I always
say to people when I present
is don't necessarily use
it the way I do, okay?
Take what I do and make it your own.
Here's how I do it.
I'm not saying it's right.
By the way I'm not saying
I've got it figured out
'cause there's changes I
make with Suzy by the way.
Suzy and I are big Khan Academy users.
We get together and talk all the time.
"I liked how we did this, maybe
we should do that instead."
So make it your own, make it
something that you can use
the information on there to
help you be a better teacher.
It is not there to teach
your students for you.
Now the videos in a time like this,
yeah, they might be there
to teach your students
because you can't be there 24/7.
And it's great to be
able to rewind and pause.
And Sal Khan in one of
his Ted talks talks about
how his cousin said they
like him better in his videos
than in person.
And he kind of said, once you
get past the backended nature
of that comment, he goes,
"They don't feel like
"they're bothering the video of me
"because they can pause, they can rewind,
"they can do things."
So it is just another tool.
For me, the way I use it, you hear me,
I talk about the exercises
and I want it to be
that the students use the exercises.
So you use the exercise data to decide
what it is my students need.
- Cool, and then let me actually ask you
one final question here
Shalom before we wrap.
Tying into this question of like looking
at students' scores,
figuring what they need,
I know that a lot of the
pressure's off for this year
in terms of state assessments,
but if we wanna continue
to use assessments
just to keep track of
how students are doing,
are there any recommendations you have?
This is a question from Kelly by the way,
to use Khan Academy to inform
the assessments you're doing?
- We talked about this before.
I don't have a great answer to that
because the Khan Academy
assessments are really not,
to me they're not summative assessments.
They're formative.
So I look at it not as like,
"Okay, here's a onetime assessment
"and let's see what the kids know."
I look at it more as an
ongoing set of data for me.
We're working on negative
numbers, addition and subtraction
and oh, by the way, a bunch
of my kids are struggling
with absolute value to find distance.
It happens all the time,
that's a very difficult skill, right?
So I use it on an ongoing basis
to make formative assessment
decisions as I teach.
I don't really think that it
is a good assessment tool.
Not that it's a bad, but
it's not necessarily designed
to be an assessment tool
that like at the end of
or middle of the year,
let's give the kids this,
okay, now I know what they need to,
let's focus more on this or that.
It's more of an ongoing assessment tool,
if that makes sense.
- Absolutely 'cause students
are constantly getting feedback
on how they're doing.
You're receiving those
same reports on your side.
Use that to empower your students,
empower you as an educator,
not to be the final word about
how your students did.
Speaking of final words, any
final words of wisdom, Shalom
as American educators head
out for another big week
of preparation next week?
- Other than, don't be
jealous of the headset.
Understand that, I know
you're frustrated right now
and I know the last thing
you need is somebody saying,
"Hey, you should use this.
"Hey, you should use that."
Every website out there is like,
"Yeah, we're giving this for free now
"and this is for free," right?
But they're gonna go and when
this is all said and done,
they're gonna go and say,
"Hey, remember that thing
"we gave you for free?
"It's gonna go away now.
"Your district or you're
gonna have to pay for it."
And it's gimmicky.
Khan Academy, if there's
one thing about it,
it is not a gimmick.
It is based on research,
mastery-based learning
I think is the way to,
it's the way we learn everything.
We learn how to ride a bike,
we learn how to play an instrument,
we learn how to do
everything by practicing
until we're good at it.
And this is the kind of thing
that I know it's hard to think
of like, "Oh my God, I'm gonna
dive into something now."
But if you do, you're going
to see the benefits of it
and you might not use
it anything like I do,
it might be completely
different for you, all right?
I don't expect people to
do it the way I do it.
But dive into it like I said,
give the kids a few exercises,
see where the data takes you,
see where the information
you get takes you.
So I wish everybody good luck
and make sure to join the teachers' page.
I don't know if I said
that before on Facebook.
Khan Academy teachers'
page or Teach with Khan.
There's a lot of ambassadors
and just otherwise experienced
Khan Academy teachers
on there that are gonna,
they're happy to answer your questions
because they've been in
the same position as you.
They've been at the point
where they didn't understand something.
So go on there, ask some questions.
- That's amazing.
I will include that in the chat section.
As mentioned before, if we didn't get
to your question today, my apologies.
Please just submit it right here,
which I've shared through
the chat line to get help
within a few hours from our
amazing customer support team.
And then finally, a
huge shout out to Shalom
for sharing his expertise today.
I know it's a lot on our
shoulders at the moment,
but I feel like you've ease
our burden a little bit
and given us reason to be
confident about the future.
So thank you, Shalom.
- Thank you for having me
and good luck everybody.
- Have a great one everyone.